hey welcome to my channel i decided to
start a four course tutorial showing you
guys
how to give your shots a filmic look at
the end of these series i'll export all
the film looks
as presets for you to download and use
in your own projects
these presets will be absolutely free
and for personal and for commercial
usage
so stick around to the end and let's
learn together
how to achieve the filmic look okay so a
little bit of
a backstory last year i did my first
exhibition
photos exhibition and i've chosen
some of my best works from the past
three four years as a photographer
and i re-edit each of them
to make sure that they are exactly
as i want them to be and the best
quality possible
and i thought okay this would be cool if
i would show
people how i actually edit my pictures
and
what i think uh it's important when you
edit your shots so as you can see
this is the before this is after this
was shot on a 50 mil
lens 1.8 manual focus
uh this is a 75 millimeter equivalent on
a full frame
and as you can see this is this is
actually out of focus like his eyes
are out of focus i think i focused on
his ear
but that's yeah so
let's start by pressing f7 for a new
variant
this is on windows cool and
what i always do when i start editing i
just
go to the details tab bring down
all the sharpening because i don't need
it since this is shot on digital
there's a lot of information a lot of
details no problem
okay next thing bring up the brightness
bring down the contrast because i want
to have as much control as possible over
the image
uh bring up the exposure just a little
bit okay cool
and now we can see now we can see what
we're working with
actually like how much detail how much
noise
there is in the shot so go back to the
details tab
i usually bring down the luminance
because anyways at the end of the
edit i'll just add a little bit more
grain no problem
so luminance will take that out and
smoothen
everything i don't really want that okay
uh what i'll do
i'll bring the single pixel all the way
up and what that does
it kind of kind of gets you kind of gets
rid of
all the dead pixels or hot pixels and
you can bring it
all the way up to 100 because it's
non-destructive it
will not affect your image so that's
super super cool
okay so first first things first we can
see like compared to
uh to the edit i've done before
this is super hot okay this is like
a super yellow red ish so let's bring it
down
to let's say 3 800
on the kelvin slider and bring down the
tint
so we make it green okay something like
that
okay i'll bring up maybe a little bit
more of the shadow so you can see more
details here in the face
cool as you can see here if we notice
there is like a purple fringing from the
sensor
i think the sensor had some kind of
issues because i bought it
um it was resealed
and i didn't notice this problem until a
couple months after i bought the camera
but that's okay it's not a problem for
me anymore and it wasn't a problem even
before
because i was using this camera for
personal projects or just my own
pictures whatever
what i usually do with my pictures i'm
going for a really soft look okay
i'm i'm going for something more like a
moody
uh dark look okay so maybe just bring
it a little bit more to green side good
and now
i'll bring up the exposure just a little
bit more and then crush
the whites so if you notice when you
crush the whites
the image becomes darker okay
so let's do it like so maybe bring down
the exposure just a little bit
good now saturation a little bit down
cool and actually what i'm going to do
bring up all the way up the saturation
so we can see all the colors we're
working
with at the moment just you know
and let's go to the color editor press
the three buttons
right there and here you can see each
color channel individually and this is
super super helpful because
uh here you you can see actually what
you're working with
and uh which parts um which
channel like how much color information
is in each channel
so i want to remove that purple fringing
from here so
we're looking into the magenta pink and
even a little bit of the reddish
tone so we need to go to each channel
individually and just turn it
off okay maybe in the red one just a
little bit
exactly okay now go back just to the
saturation and bring it
down like so cool maybe
add a little bit of vignetting and now
as you can see
we kind of like got rid of the purple
fringing cool
that's nice okay maybe i've crushed a
little bit too much
bring it back a little bit okay add some
green
and mixture and the highlights and then
some blue
in the shadows maybe a little bit too
much
and um and let's see can we tweak a
little bit like that like so cool
okay maybe in the mid tones add just a
little bit more red
so the face is you know
it's not completely green even though
that's not bad but
trying to make something else here cool
something like that
yeah okay that's it cool
also maybe go here let's check some
other colors maybe the yellow
i wanted to saturate the yellows a
little bit because i don't like what's
going on around here
super super nasty as i've said this this
was
underexposed big time and uh
the colors are kind of kind of bad
around here so let's go into the yellow
one
and just the saturated see okay not that
much but
in the saturated just a little bit like
so cool
maybe go more like uh
so now i'm doing some fine tuning
cool maybe now even less
saturation just like that okay cool
okay
okay so this is it
this is it and for the final
adjustment i'll just zoom in a little
bit and even add a little bit more grain
some people might not like that because
they don't like their shots
grainy maybe they like it smooth that's
okay no problem
it's your decision uh i'll just add
a little bit more silver rich film crane
uh so my favorites are kind of like
silver rich cubic grain
this is like a little bit finer than the
silver one
and tabular but tabular it's sometimes a
little bit too harsh
so i bring down the granulat i'll bring
down the granularity
but um silver rich for me at least
it's the most natural so i really like
that one
cool something like this okay so
let's check it out this was the before
and this is the after
so thank you for watching uh i hope you
found this
tutorial helpful and if you want a more
in-depth tutorial on color grading and
how to get different looks just let me
know in the comments
and i'll i'll make some new tutorials
see you in the next one
see ya